[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact most people know that
spiders have eight legs and no wings but
that's why you might be surprised to
learn that some spiders can actually fly
hundreds of miles it's true when
conditions are right young spiders climb
to an exposed point they raise their
abdomens to the sky release long strands
of silk and float up up and away this
behavior is called ballooning spiders
might do this to carry themselves away
from predators or towards new lands with
better resources whatever the reason it
seems to be a very effective means of
travel incredibly scientists have
recently discovered the spiders are not
carried aloft by the wind but by
electricity evidently the little
arachnids can detect when the air is
transformed through electrical storms
then they release a few yards of their
spider silk that is drawn upward by a
positive charge in the upper atmosphere
they then release their hold on earth
and up they go in a process called
electrostatic repulsion this is the same
static electricity principle that makes
your hair stand on end when you rub a
balloon on it with the help of a good
breeze these gliders spiders have been
found floating over 1,000 miles from
land and 16,000 feet up in the air you
know the Bible says there's a day coming
when all the Christians will rise in the
skies stay with his friends were going
to learn more on this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 phone call and
if you call now good chance to get your
Bible question on tonight's program
here's the number 800 4 6 3 7 2 97
that's 800 God says get your pencil here
you go one more time
804 6 3 7 2 97
we're not only on this radio station but
we are streaming live on Facebook and
that would be the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page and the amazing facts
Facebook page and I am Doug Batchelor my
name is John Ross good evening listening
friends and pastor Doug let's start the
program with prayer dear father we thank
you that we have this opportunity to
open up your word and study together we
do ask your blessing upon this program
we know that the Bible is your book and
so we pray for the Holy Spirit to guide
our hearts our minds as we search the
Scriptures in Jesus name Amen amen
opacity opened the program by talking
about a spider
flying in the air more than a thousand
miles now you know it's one thing for
the spider to death maybe float from one
tree to another but to float a thousand
miles I mean that's amazing yeah it's
kind of like imagine for a moment that
you've got a kite that is so big and so
powerful that you don't let go and it
pulls you right off the ground they do
that with their webs they just they
release this web and it grabs so much of
the static electricity in the air that
it pulls moments by baby spiders are
they weigh almost nothing we've all
you know probably grabbed a spiderweb
why spider was still hanging on it maybe
not I did but I didn't wait anything and
so they just the the electricity in the
air they sense when the positive charges
have changed and it just pulls them up
and they can go a long way so and that's
you know they say spiders are in every
continent in the world just about
everywhere but Antarctica there's
nothing lives there but penguins I think
in some seals but yeah it made me think
about how you've got this this power
that nobody can see that was levitating
the spiders they noticed some of them
did it when there was almost no breeze
at all and they thought how do they do
this so they've tested this now and
they've actually created rooms where
they've got an electric charge they
create and the spider sense it they
start to kind of bounce on their feet
and they they put their little rear ends
in the air and they start to release the
silk and it draws them up and then the
scientists turn off the charge the
spiders all drop and so they know this
is what it's been but you know the Bible
tells us that there's going to be a
special power that will draw us up into
the air in the future let me read you
about this friends it's in 1st
Thessalonians 4:16 through 18 for the
Lord Himself will descend from heaven
with a shout with the voice of an
archangel and the trumpet of God and the
dead in Christ will rise first then we
who are alive and remain will be caught
up together with them in the clouds to
meet the lord in the air and thus we
will always be with the Lord so the
Bible is pretty clear that when the Lord
comes every believer who has ever lived
is going up the dead in Christ are risen
with the glorified bodies and they are
caught up to meet the Lord in the air
and the righteous who are alive get
transformed and they are we hear the
word raptured up that means they're
caught up now one thing many Christians
are confused about is they think well
isn't this rapture a secret you know
nowhere in the bible does it say the
rapture is a secret it's actually the
most obvious thing in the world the time
of Christ's coming there's a great
secret he said he's coming like a thief
but when a thief comes usually no it
and in the same way when the Lord comes
the Bible says it's like lightning
shining from the east to the west
there's a great earthquake there's a
resurrection there's a great hail you
know everything our senses is a light it
says every eye will see him when he
comes so this idea that Christ comes
secretly and people disappear and life
goes on here on earth for another seven
years that's a fairly recent teaching
most Christians for the last sixteen
eighteen hundred years have believed in
a very literal visible glorious return
of Jesus and the we will be caught up to
meet him in the air during that time now
we have a free offer if you'd like to
understand more about the subject of the
rapture when it's gonna happen and the
Second Coming we have a free offer for
you the book that we have that we'll
give to anyone for free is called
anything but secret very important
subject talking about the second coming
of Christ and when the Saints are caught
up this is a free offer tonight all
you'll have to do is call us on our
resource phone line and that's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and just answer the book called
anything but secret that phone number
again is 883 five six seven four seven
as for the book anything but secret
we'll be happy to send it to anyone in
North America and if you have a Bible
related question the phone line here to
the studio is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven and we
ready to go to the phone lines the first
call of this evening is William
listening in New Mexico William welcome
to the program god bless you brother how
you doing doing good thanks for calling
amen thank you hey I want to ask the
question does God forgive reoccurring
sins I know he says you know to guard
your heart he says to be aware the devil
is like a lion roaring to her first seek
you knew he can devour
go ahead I'm sorry no I just want to
know because you know I I'm gonna be
honest with you I fell this morning what
I did call God prayer rededicated my
life to the Lord
you know I feel good and let me tell you
it's a struggle every day and I know God
said it wouldn't be easy but I love the
Lord and I love his work well so the
question is first of all if God only
four if God doesn't forgive reoccurring
sins then we're in trouble you know the
Bible says a righteous man falls and I
forget the verse but it says a righteous
man falls seven times and rises again I
don't know if that's proverbs
Bible tells us about Mary Magdalene out
of whom Jesus cast Seven Devils and so
and you have that verse ya proverbs 24
verse 16 but in order for him to rise
again every time we fall the Bible says
if we sin we should confess and repent
of our sins and he will cleanse us from
all unrighteousness so you know you want
to keep as they say short accounts with
God if we do fall then we should you
know as soon as we're aware that we've
fallen we should genuinely repent that's
not just saying oh Lord I want to I want
to make sure I'm saved but I plan on
doing this again tomorrow well that's
not repentance repentance is a sorrow
for sin and a willingness to stop now
you may fall several times before you
stop but whenever we repent God will
always forgive a man confess and repent
our sins you know William we have a book
that you might be interested in it's
cold assurance justification made simple
and we'll be happy to send this to you
or anyone wanting to learn more about
the subject of forgiveness and
transformation again the number is 883
five six seven four seven and you can
answer the book called assurance
justification made simple DG no amazing
facts has a free Bible school that you
can do from the comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 for 257,000 that's
one 844 two one five 7,000
a next caller that we have is David
listening from Long Island New York
David welcome to the program hi thank
you thank you for having me thanks for
calling and your question so my question
my question is its reference to I guess
the 6,000 year history of the Bible and
if it starts with if it starts with Adam
how do we reconcile I guess a global
history of you know 15,000 years or more
was there man
I guess the relationship of Adam to
Christ the genealogy was that just the
the notion of God had to establish a
direct line to Christ or was there MIT
was there man prior to Adam there were
there are other beings well there's
really two questions first when you
asked about the genealogy from Adam to
Jesus we're fairly certain that you can
add up the ages in the dates it tells
how long Adam lived and Seth and eNOS
and Lane McCall the way up to Abraham
and and indeed you can trace history
from Abraham to Jesus and we know Jesus
lived approximately 2,000 years ago the
problem is with the dating methods that
are being used by some they're usually
atheistic scientists they they're
they're trying to say create these long
histories for Humanity and you know the
the only way that they can do the dating
and know for certain is educated guesses
we do not know when they use radio
isotope carbon-14 dating they do not
know that that's accurate beyond 2000
years and so when they start saying yeah
this this dates back fifteen thousand
years they keep they keep reevaluating
sometimes they're doing they're dating
not by carbon-14 but they look at the
tools and they say well these look like
primitive tools that must have been from
a much further to tell you know that man
is using much longer period of time so I
think that the the dates that they give
are extremely speculative
and I believe the Bible history now you
know what I think is interesting
David you still there yes I'm still here
there's no trees in the world that they
can really date beyond 4,000 years the
oldest living trees are about four
thousand years and it goes back to about
the time of the flood there's some
Bristlecone pine that may have survived
the flood there's no written history how
come man you go back 4,000 years or
2,000 years maybe yeah 2,000 years BC
and all of a sudden you've got these
Egyptians you know if you believe the
archaeologists man is dragging his
knuckles around and he wakes up and he
built a pyramid and he's writing and
he's math as extreme Kulas going on I
mean all of a sudden he goes from
nothing to this genius well it's that's
hard to explain and you look at the
Mesopotamian civilizations and there
they were writing very sophisticated
math on cuneiform and it all seems to
spring out of nowhere about the same
time the Bible says that man was created
so going back fifteen thousand years I
just don't have those are usually very
speculative guesses that are being made
so you know what there's a timeline that
I think you would enjoy if you it's a
website anyone out there if you want to
see what the Bible timelines say it's
called I think it's Bible History com
mm-hmm just type in Bible history calm
you there's a visual timeline you can
drag it back and forth to kind of neat
it'll line it up with the dates that
different people lived a years of
research went into preparing this and I
think that you'll enjoy that Bible
history com great biblical timeline
matches up with the history of the world
thank you for your call David I hope
that helps a little no thank you very
much doc I really appreciate it all
right god bless you have a good evening
hi Mexico lover behave is Kyle and he's
listening in Texas Kyle welcome to the
program hey can you hear me we can
sounds like you're on the road yeah I am
on the road I'm paying
I'm paying to object okay and so your
question tonight my question is
concerning the rapture that you were
talking about earlier the 1st
Thessalonians 4 yes um so I've heard
about the rapture
first Thessalonians 4 and then I come
across two different scriptures that I
want to see how they tie into the first
death lines for one of them is in 2nd
Thessalonians chapter 2 when Paul write
that the day of the Lord will find no
means come until the falling away
happens first and the man of sin is
revealed and and then the other one is
in Revelation 20 when we see all of the
saints on Thrones and the ones that can
be headed and went through all the
trials and tribulation after all the
seals the trumpets and the bowls and
everything right and then it's that this
is the first resurrection and the rest
of the Dead did not rise until after the
thousand years were finished so this is
if this is the first resurrection and
we're seeing the resurrection in 1st
Thessalonians 4 they must be the same am
I correct
the resurrection in Revelation 20 now
nothing personal Kyle we're gonna bring
your volume down just because we're
getting a little road noise I think
it'll make it easier for everyone to
hear and then we'll pull you back up if
you have a further comment 1st
Thessalonians 4 is talking about when
the Lord descends when he comes next and
the resurrection happens and we're too
saved or caught up to meet the Lord in
the air you're finding that also
referenced in Revelation chapter 20 when
in Revelation 20 it's talking about the
Millenium beginning Satan is bound and
at the beginning of the 1,000 years is
the second coming of the Lord when the
dead in Christ rise the rest of the dead
the wicked they don't live again till
the thousand years are finished the ones
who are raised in at the second coming
that's called the first resurrection so
John is just making the distinction
between the wicked who come forth again
for the judgment at the end of the
thousand years are not the same group
that is raised at the beginning of the
millennium and then the verse in 2nd
Thessalonians 2 it says they're not the
Lord will not come until there comes a
falling away first
well yeah we agree with that there's
gonna be a great falling away in the
church before the Lord comes there was
quite a big falling away in the church
during the dark ages and it'll be
especially bad before the Second Coming
when you know people are worshiping the
Beast any thoughts on that Kyle yeah I
was just curious because I've always
heard that the church will be taken away
before the Antichrist comes but
according to second Thessalonians it
seems that he will come first before
there is a resurrection and the coming
of our Lord exactly I think you're right
on track there you know the folks that
believe that that the church is going to
be caught away they said well you know
the Lord loves the church too much for
it to be here during the seven last
plagues but that's not true
when when the ten plagues fell on Egypt
God's people were in Egypt and he
protected them through the last seven of
the ten plagues God saves us not from
tribulation Paul says it is through
tribulation we enter the kingdom of God
and you know that offer that we're
making available tonight is exactly what
I think you'd enjoy reading it's called
anything but secret talks about the
tribulation in the second coming the
rapture to the number to call for that
is 808 three five six seven four seven
and again after the book called anything
but secret we'll be happy to send it to
you Kyle or anyone who calls and asks
next caller that we have is David
listening in Michigan David welcome to
the program good evening pastors hi hi
thanks be unto God for this great hope
he gives us in Christ not only now but
in what's coming amen amen
my question is from first Corinthians
chapter 15 where Paul was writing to the
Brethren
I'll read the these few verses real
quick here he says moreover brethren I
declare unto you the gospel which I
preached unto you and which also you
have received and where you stand by
which also you are saved if you keep in
memory what I preached unto you unless
you believed in vain
for I delivered unto you first of all
that which I also received how that
Christ died for our sins according to
the scriptures that he was buried
that he rose again the third day
according to the scriptures my question
here is is I've always understood what
is written here as being when Paul says
according to the scriptures that Christ
died for our sins here I've always
understood it as being he died for our
sins according to what was prophesied of
him but then another understanding has
come to my mind and I'm unsure if this
is the proper way to understand what
also Paul may have intended or what we
may also understand here how that we
could understand that Christ died for
our sins according to the sins that are
listed in scriptures and the reason I
also led to think that way is because he
he's writing this he says to the
Brethren in the first one he says
moreover brethren Christ died for our
sins according to the scriptures so I'm
kind of divided as to know whether it's
safe to believe that he's talking about
the sins that are mentioned in the
scriptures as being those sins which he
died for I think your first
interpretation is correct that it's
saying that when Jesus died for our sins
according to the scriptures Paul is
referring them back to the prophecies
that the Messiah would come as a
sacrifice the reason I say that is Jesus
the first sermon he gave after he rose
from the dead to the two disciples on
the road to Emmaus he told them and this
is I think Luke 24 I forget the verse he
says Oh fools and slow of heart to
believe all that the prophets have
spoken beginning at Moses and all the
prophets he expounded unto them in all
the Scriptures the things concerning
himself so it was a common phrase Peter
does it at Pentecost and I think he
Peter does it again in Acts chapter 3 it
was common for the Apostles to say Jesus
coming the Messiah coming to die is
according to the scriptures and they're
talking about scriptures like Isaiah 53
so I think you're first understanding is
a correct one I don't think it's talking
necessarily about the sins of the
scriptures and of course the the sins of
the scriptures would be violation of
God's Ten Commandments because
transgression or sin is the
transgression of God's law which
of course the Scriptures do make very
clear and plain it reveals to us what
God's will is so yes in one sense Christ
died for the sins according to the
Scriptures meaning the Scriptures point
out that Jesus would die for our sins
but it also reveals to us what sin is I
thank you for that so you would say that
the second interpretation which I
mentioned it shouldn't be believed at
all that there's nothing really there at
all is inspired of the Holy Spirit to to
be believed well I think that what Paul
is saying here when the disciples say
Christ died for our sins according to
the Scriptures the scriptures of course
tell about the Messiah coming to die and
that Jesus died for our sins which is
the transgression of all also it
basically it's all-encompassing I
suppose both yeah and that was kind of
it
that was kind of the beauty of what I
was seeing is that you could probably
receive both of them and I just wanted
to clarify and see if you guys also saw
the same thing just as you're saying
that I'm kind of thinking about it I'm
thinking well I guess it works either
way because the Scriptures is such a
broad comprehensive term typically I've
read this to mean that the Scriptures
had prophesied that Jesus would come the
first time to die they were all so
shocked when he died and he kept telling
them you know this is what was foretold
and I it says it twice in Luke 24 hey
thank you very much for your call I'm
trying to think you know you might enjoy
we've got a book that talks about the
scriptures and the prophecies of Christ
that's right call the ultimate resource
yes talking about the Bible and we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
and asks the number is 883 five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book the ultimate resource we have Kenny
listening from Indianapolis Kenny
welcome to the program
oh hi buster but the Ross hosta Bachelor
hi a special shout-out to cluster Ross
or Regional Forum Zimbabwe so right next
door the way he comes okay
and your question tonight we're speaking
about in millenium I've been wondering
this for a while now that you know when
we come back to after the 1000 years
this it does it express it used to make
me a little sad because it's like what
happen is so beautiful they're gonna
live all that they're behind but I also
wondered who's gonna be left of a I
guess it's always gonna be left there I
suppose I I mean are we still gonna be
able to visit up there you mean are we
able to visit up in heaven after he
moves the capital to the earth is that
what you're asking
well I must whether also the father is
he gonna remain behind when we come with
the Lord Jesus or his are they pose
coming down you know the Bible tells us
they pastor Ross and I think gone back
and forth on this one because the Bible
tells us God is omnipresent omnipresent
means that you know the the heavens of
heaven cannot contain thee Solomon as
God is everywhere and so when Christ
comes jesus said to the high priest I'm
coming on the right hand of power now
the way that's written it sounds like
Christ is he is straddled on his right
hand by the power well it's at the power
of the spirit of the power of the Father
and then yet when Jesus brings us to
heaven he presents us to the father and
a grand act of saying this is the
purchase of my blood I don't think God
is ever lonely now I think Kenny you
asking about at the end of the thousand
years right yes that's right a thousand
you're going to come down yeah you know
there's an interesting verse I'm just
looking at revelation 21 it says verse 2
and I John saw the holy city the New
Jerusalem coming down from God from
heaven prepared as a bride adorned for a
husband so that's at the end of the
thousand years but then verse 3 says and
I heard a loud voice from heaven saying
behold the tabernacle of God is with men
and he will dwell with them so
revelation 21 gives us the picture that
the New Jerusalem is on earth but that
God's dwelling place is going to be with
these people in the New Jerusalem and
the rest of the verse says it says God
shall dwell with them they shall be his
people and God himself shall be with
them and be their God
so it's almost as if the saint of the
universe or sort of yeah the the command
st. if you like is now on the earth so
it's as if things have moved yeah you
can read in chapter 22 verse 3 it says
there's no more curse for the throne of
God in the lamb shall be in it and his
servants will serve Him and they will
see his face and his name will be on
their foreheads doctor father I got the
sign it will be yes oh yeah God is he's
moving his capital here so you'll get to
see it because he's bringing it all with
him Oh wonderful
but heaven will be emptied all right
well heaven no heavens gonna move so
it's not empty
he's moving heaven okay let's move in
heaven to this planet and so I just
pictured that when the New Jerusalem
comes down he's you know right now he
says I've gone to prepare a place for
you that's up there but then he's moving
that the capital to our planet so we
will be with him and and we will see his
face
hey Kenny thank you for your question we
do have a study guide that talks about
heaven is it for real we'll send you a
free copy friends were taking a breather
break don't go anywhere
more Bible questions on your way in just
a moment
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
did you know that Noah was present to
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
Bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the Bible and draw closer
to God's Word
go deeper visit Bible History com if you
enjoy hearing solid biblical answers on
Bible answers live you can have those
same insights at your fingertips through
the amazing facts prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols charts and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope 'dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
538 7275 for life changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore com find
out what the critics are raving about
top scholars and theologians from around
the country come together to reveal the
hidden history of the book of Revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95 minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today visit iTunes or AF bookstore calm
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 72 97
i'm doug batchelor my name is John Ross
and we're gonna go back to the phone
lines we've got Yorick listening from
Miami Florida Yorick welcome to the
program car you don't matter good and
your question yes I was baptized back in
I was doing good for a while I'm a
squeeze his answer questions and I I had
an issue with marijuana for some time
but I was able to quit I just pray real
hard on it but out of fear came over me
when I did smoke I was able to quit they
have two months ago but during that time
since I got bad
Tai's I am I was off and on with it but
I think I've done it two months ago out
I finally quit I just wanna know would I
have any impact on the on my Jill on
Judgment Day with my um they should
well god I've been going to church yeah
if you've repented of your sin and if
you're returning to the Lord God will
forgive you you know you might be
wondering do I does that mean I have to
go get baptized again I wouldn't
necessarily think so you could talk to
your pastor but it sounds like you're on
the right track and by the way I used to
smoke pot - and you're making the right
decision I don't care what the law says
it makes you stupid
so you're doing the right thing yeah all
my friends that all went down that road
if they didn't get off that road it
didn't improve their lives it drugged
them down when the Bible tells us our
bodies are the temple of the Holy Spirit
we want to have clear minds because the
Holy Spirit speaks to us through our
mind thanks your call Yorick a next
color that we have is Timothy and he's
listening in Washington Timothy welcome
to the program hello thanks for calling
my question is like God choose Moses and
Abraham when the medium they mount an
harlot or you mean Moses and Elijah
Elijah I'm sorry yeah well that's a
great question why was it Moses and
Elijah that met Jesus on the holy mount
it's called the Mount of Transfiguration
you find this in mark chapter 9 there's
several reasons one is the last words
you read in the Old Testament Malachi
chapter 4 it says remember the law of
Moses my servant behold I send you a
lied to the prophet right there in the
last prophecies is remember Moses I send
you Elijah Moses and Elijah represent
the law and the prophets and so and the
other thing is when Jesus went up the
mountain before he goes up the mountain
he says to his disciples there are some
of you standing here who will not taste
of death till you see the kingdom of God
come with power then six days later this
is experience all three Gospels he makes
the statement then it tells you the next
thing about Moses and Elijah that
experience is a miniature picture of
Second Coming Christ goes up the
mountain
Moses is there representing those who
died and are resurrected Elijah was
there he never died he was translated he
was caught up to meet the Lord that
represents everyone saved when Jesus
comes Christ is glorified as he will be
when he comes God the Father is there
saying this is my beloved son and so I
think that it's a good picture for the
second coming
so Moses represents the law Elisha
represents the prophets we need an
experience in the law and the prophets
that's the Word of God to be ready for
the second coming now it's interesting
jesus prayed that the disciples would
their faith would be strengthened a few
weeks after the experience on that
mountain Christ was on a different
mountain but instead of being robed in
white he was stripped instead of Moses
and Elijah there were two thieves
instead of angels singing there was
cursing he was on Mount Calvary so he
gave them this experience to strengthen
their faith and prepare them for Mount
Calvary now we got a free book we'll be
happy to send you that talks about this
brother if you're still there and it's
called the glorious mount talks about
the two witnesses that's the Word of God
then I'm gonna Coley's 883 five six
seven four seven and you can ask for the
book called the glorious mount we'll be
happy to send that out to anyone who
calls and asks next quarter that we have
his dawn listening from Florida dawn
welcome to the program hi my question is
about X 919 yes it talks about Paul
going to Damascus this is right after he
has a encounter with the Risen Jesus
mm-hmm is this when he receives the
Apostles Creed well let me just go there
real quick Acts 919 you say yes and hang
on here I want to look at this so when
he received food he was strengthened
then Saul spent some days with the
disciples at Damascus there's no record
in the Bible that he receives the
Apostles Creed why he's in Damascus I
think Paul spent some time with
believers in Damascus it tells us about
Ananias who came and talked to him and
there were
other believers he was actually on his
way to arrest those believers when he
has his dramatic conversion experience
but where are you reading that the
Apostles Creed came only through Paul
nohe Paul talks about receiving he says
I am delivering to you what of what was
delivered to me what was given to me and
I was thinking you know that when he met
with the disciples at Damascus he would
tell him I've encountered the Risen
Jesus and then they would tell him also
about the Apostles Creed then it just
seemed that makes sense
well I you know I'm sure that while he
was with the disciples they were telling
him the foundational principles of the
gospel and then later Paul goes to
Jerusalem and he meets with Peter and
the others I think the verse you might
be referring to you 1st Corinthians
chapter 11 verse 23 where Paul writes
and he says for I received from the Lord
that which I also delivered to you and
then he goes on to talk about how that
the Lord Jesus on the same night in
which it was betrayed he took bread and
he broke it and thought and so on so in
that context is he's saying I'm giving
you what I received from the Lord oh so
he received it from from from Christ
according to verse 23 in 1st Corinthians
yeah Paul Paul the only time Jesus spoke
to Paul on the road to Damascus but
Christ actually spoke to Paul several
times in fact when Paul talks about the
thorn in his side he says the abundance
of revelations that I've had God to keep
me humble Christ spoke to him once he
said I've got many in this city don't
get discouraged another time he said
don't be discouraged you're gonna
testify for me in Rome and other time
Paul's on the ship and the Lord appears
to him and said I've given you everybody
in the boat you've been praying for
Paul had a really close relationship
with Jesus and Christ spoke to him many
times yeah I just trying to nail down
see if I could nail down the Pennell the
time line well he did get his initial
instruction in Damascus you're correct
he did get some foundational instruction
there because that's when he first found
out that Jesus was the Messiah
and the disciples in Damascus probably
gave him some elementary training and
the Lord spoke to him there as well okay
well we appreciate your question done
thank you so much appreciate your call
thank you once a know God's plan for our
world and solutions for your life's
challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts
twenty-seven Bible study guides provide
encouraging Bible based answers to
questions on healthier relationships
when Jesus will return and much more
refer to watch while you read our brand
new prophecy encounters DVD series makes
the perfect companion set order your
study guides and DVDs today by visiting
AAF bookstore calm or by calling 858
seven two seven five next caller that we
have is Roger listening in Colorado
Roger welcome to the program thank you
for having me
and I like that little statue you people
have in front of you yeah you know what
that is we don't worship statues that's
us that's a copy of an image you find in
Daniel chapter 2 exactly for our friends
who are watching on Facebook you can see
the video we've got this little Daniel 2
statue that's the vision of the history
of the world
okay my question has to do with the the
book Ezekiel chapter 1 it creatures and
wheels one of them is a man a lion an ox
and an eagle but in chapter 10 it's a
cherub man lion and eagle why did the
arcs change to a cherub well let me just
look here in chapter 10 let me see here
fill your hands with coals from among
the chair of them scatter them what
verse you looking at I'm not exactly I'm
I just wrote this down from a study that
I was doing it says mentions images have
seen in Chapter 1 creatures and wheels
yeah oh yeah I see here each one had
four faces you're right in verse 14 each
one had four faces the face of a cherub
the second the face of a man the third
the face of a lion the force the face of
an eagle it's like the word cherub
there's in place of a calf for one I
don't know now a cherub would have Cosby
the being with wings and these four
living creatures are described as having
wings
and having four different faces so
instead of specifically mentioning the
ox he refers to the cherub meaning the
being that has the wings now all four
then do have wings you know in Chapter
go ahead I'm sorry I was just gonna say
when you go to Revelation chapters at
four you've got the same creatures you
got one like a lion one like an eagle
one like a man and one like a calf or an
ox
so the Ezekiel vision is very much like
the Revelation vision so I would try and
figure out the chapter 9 or 10 verse 14
part it's an interesting revelation 9 10
revelation 4 chapter 4 Revelation
chapter 4 talks about the full living
creature surrounding the throne okay I
thank you very much for that alright and
thank you and yeah I'm just looking
you'll you'll see the that in Revelation
chapter 4 verse 6 you can start with
that okay thank you very much all right
thanks appreciate your call Roger you
got it a next caller that we have is
Randy listening Canada Rainey welcome to
the program hey how are you doing good
um so I have this question dog has been
bugging me for a while now and it's
about the Trinity it never got to my
mind how Jesus is equal to God and in
that sense because anywhere and the
Bible Jesus never claimed to be equal
with God through his journey and I was
reading Isaiah 53 I'm sure you know it
it's my servant grew up in the Lord's
presence like a tender green chute is he
talking about Jesus here well Isaiah 53
is a prophecy about Christ but when it
says he grew up it's talking about one
Christ the incarnation of Christ once
Christ became a man
but anyway kick go ahead with your
question okay so and it made more sense
than yes and John that he is the word
and everything was created through him
and nothing was created except through
him so yes that makes sense to me that
ok everything was created through Jesus
but I feel that even Jesus of he was
speaking
his journey there's a leadership here
from the Father as if in a hierarchy
position that's that's what I'm getting
from what I've been reading well I would
not disagree that there is a respect for
varying roles in the Godhead it you read
for instance God the father gives
judgment to the son god the father
creates everything through the son John
3:16 God the Father so loved the world
he takes the initiative gives the son
and so I I do think he find all through
the New Testament anyway that there is a
willing submission or a wrote an
acceptance of roles within the Godhead
the Holy Spirit is always asking us to
glorify the father Jesus never says pray
to me in the father's name he says pray
to the Father in my name ok so there's a
form of hierarchy because the Trinity
house I want to use the word hierarchy
but I I know what you're saying
yeah I would say that there's a willing
submission God the Father Son and spirit
are all perfectly equal a husband and
wife can be perfectly equal equal but
they can have different roles in nature
yeah and value yet in in different roles
that's because how it's explained
usually in churches there there's like
equal on all levels even like hierarchy
or lack of submission basically there's
no submission from any it's the same God
this is where I like it doesn't make
sense because Jesus never claimed that
he's fully at the same level I want to
say of hierarchy in a way or leadership
position well there's there's one place
in Philippians and pastor also help me
find it where it says he did not count
at robbery I think it's polar beans for
he did not count at Robert he'd be equal
with God yeah made himself of no
reputation Philippians 2 beginning with
verse 5 let this mind be in you which
was also in Christ Jesus who being in
the form of God did not consider it
robbery to be equal with God but made
himself of no reputation taking upon
himself the form of a
and coming in the likeness of men yeah
and you know when Christ rises from the
dead Thomas says my Lord and my god and
Jesus doesn't say don't say that when
when John the Apostle tries to worship
an angel the angel stops him but when
the disciples worship Jesus at the
resurrection he says all hail and they
fall before him jesus said before
Abraham was I am which is referring to
the name given to God in the Exodus
story with God was speaking with Moses
at the burning bush yeah in the
beginning God created and Jesus created
so I think there you know for our for
our purposes he is co-equal with the
Father as far as power now Jesus did
something and humbling himself in
becoming a man he kind of laid aside a
part of his divinity and and that's a
mystery and the Bible talks about this
mystery of godliness how what happened
in God the son when he was in vitro in
Mary and what happened to God the Sun in
the tomb everyone wonders about that did
he stop being God and how could he cease
to exist and folks struggle with that I
just say well when I get to him and I'm
going to ask him that too but the Bible
says and I believe in Christ died it
doesn't say that he went through a
metamorphose so hey I hope that helps
Randy I do have a book I'll send you a
free copy and it's called the Trinity
one God or three and just call and ask
for that then I'm going to call these
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven after the book on the Trinity
it's called one God all three the
Trinity and pastor day I'm just looking
at the book right there it happens to be
lying on the desk
exploring the Trinity yeah I left up for
what's called exploring the Trinity one
God or three again the number is 883
five six seven four seven D G new
amazing facts has a free Bible school
that you can do from the comfort of your
own home it includes 27 beautifully
illustrated study lessons to aid in your
study of God's Word sign up today for
this free Bible study course by calling
184 257,000 that's one eight four four
two one five 7,000
next one of the behaved is Lamar
listening in Chicago Lamar welcome to
the program
hi passes how you guys doing we're doing
great how can we help you tonight I've
got a question and it comes from
Revelations it's a few verses but I'm
just gonna read one revelation 17 verse
what's a acceptabie without solace was
and it's not and sure the scene out of
the bottomless pit and go into perdition
and they that dwell on the earth shall
wonder whose name's not written in the
book of life from the foundation of the
world whom they behold the Beast their
work and it's not yeah is so my question
is when I look up the word that the word
position talks about eternal punishment
so is that talking about the time of the
fire or there before the fire well of
course all those the beasts and all
those that worship the Beast will
ultimately be in the lake of fire and
that's in Revelation chapter 20 and 21 I
thought you're gonna ask who that beast
was it wasn't is not and yet is
are you wondering about the word
perdition I think the word perdition
there means it means utter destruction
or end now you know it's described there
is this beast power that was and then it
seems to suffer this deadly wound but
then suddenly it is revived and the
question is is this beast ever going to
come to an end well verse 8 says it will
come to an end its perdition is sure
meaning its destruction is sure that
destruction begins just at the time of
the second coming where it talks about
the the Antichrist power being destroyed
with the brightness of Christ coming but
then at the end of the thousand years
you have the great white throne judgment
and that's where the Bible says the
Beast of the false prophet are cast into
the lake of fire so so that's what I
want me there they start before the lake
of fire or like there's a body when they
start doing started four thousand years
when the bottomless pit or does it start
at like a fire after a thousand years
both the beastin is not thrown into the
lake of fire until after the 1000 years
the the beasts power is destroyed with
the brightness of Christ coming at the
beginning of the thousand years and then
like you say pastor Dyke at the end it's
this power is resurrected once again
everybody acknowledges
Christ and that God is fair then the
fire that destroys the wicked know we
have that lesson on the Millennium and
our lesson on judgment both talked about
that and maybe we could send Lamar a
free copy yes just asked for the lesson
called a thousand years of peace it
talks about Revelation chapter 20 the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and again you can ask for the study
guide called a thousand years of peace
next Kali is Andy and he's listening
from Florida Amy welcome to the program
Andy are you there you might have your
mute on hi hi and your question hi first
I have to say I've been trying to get on
this program since 2008 this is my first
time I finally know why I'm so sorry to
hear it's been so hard well welcome
it's okay I do enjoy listening to the
podcast afterwards so I took it's it's
it's okay
thank you um first of all I enjoy the
work you guys are doing I've been
following you Pastor for a very very
very very long time and I love you
making me sell old the too many varies
in there yes it's true I've been
following you for a very long time and
got it using you and I pray that he
continued to do so well you and I both
thank you so much and how can we help
you tonight Andy I have a question about
I'm trying to figure out what the Bible
says about certain holidays that are not
biblical for instance I work at ITT and
in my company there's always there's
MIDI there's a lot of Indians and they
said they haven't you know how the the
Hinduism religion they have a lot of
gods they celebrate and they have many
holidays they celebrate and every time
they celebrating those holidays there's
day they bring food and then they have
decoration and stuff like that that it's
they say waiting for their God and I'm
wondering what and I always feel
uncomfortable being they are taking part
of their holidays and I'm anytime they
would come to me and say hey we didn't
see you at the party we didn't see you
and and and and I'm trying to find a
biblical I want to know what
but I will say about that and how could
i I want to have an answer to give them
and not send tonight and I'm not sure
how to go about it well that is a good
question you know the Bible does
actually say something about eating food
sacrificed to idols and the Bible also
says if anything is not of faith it's
sin if you're feeling uncomfortable I
sure don't want to be the holy spirit
you know you have friends you want to
win your friends you want to be nice
your friends you want to respect their
beliefs but you don't need to
participate in their beliefs now if your
friends come in and they say you know we
got these cookies because you know it's
a special holiday in our religion would
you like a cookie I want to feel like if
you ate one of your cookies one of their
cookies they thought you were worshiping
their God or sacrificing your beliefs
but if they're having a festival in the
office and you know there's it just kind
of depends on the level you don't want
to look like you're acknowledging or
recognizing their God that you don't
believe is a God at all right so you
know I just say they pray that God gives
you wisdom you can stand you know you've
got the story of Shadrach Meshach and
Abednego would not bow down to the
graven image but it's interesting they
were there so they did come when the
King says look we're having a special
celebration they came but they wouldn't
bow down good point you know as far as
possible
Paul said I try to I try to relate to
people as much as I can but don't do
anything that's gonna sacrifice your
convictions okay okay yes that's that
was that they are concerning to me I'm
like I'm thinking I they expensive me
they're their holidays the idea behind
the holidays and and and hey I also
research it as well and then I'm
comparing it with the Bible and I'm like
I don't know yeah you can't get Hinduism
and the Bible don't go together very
well
it's we do a lot of work in India and
it's it's a very different religion I
tell any brothers sister you know we
love you and you're just a nicest person
in the world but
I've got my beliefs and I'm a Christian
and it's very different from your
beliefs and just let them know where you
stand they will respect you more in the
long run if you're affirming your
beliefs
hey brother Andy I know it took you a
long time to get on the program but
we're gonna see if we can squeeze in one
more call before we run out of time and
God bless you thank you so much for your
persistence hope it's not so long before
you get on again we've got Becky
listening in Michigan Becky welcome to
the program hello parish I'm pastor Doug
hi Becky hey we've got about a minute
and a half can we do a question in that
time yes revelation 16:13 what are the
three unclean spirits yeah let me read
the verse revelation 16:13 I saw three
unclean spirits like frogs come out of
the mouth of the dragon out of the mouth
of the Beast out of the mouth of a false
prophet and it says they are the spirits
of demons that perform signs which
gather the whole world together against
God in the last days so are you
wondering what the dragon the beast and
the false prophet are it's more like the
bolts Trinity yes you've got the
counterfeit you got the dragon which
represents the devil
you've got the beast power in the last
days you read about in Revelation
chapter 13 and the false prophet is a
false interpretation of the Holy Spirit
and there's the Bible tells us in the
last days there's going to be signs and
wonders to deceive even if possible the
very elect so that's kind of what's
being described yeah a religious
movement in the last days that gathers
the whole world to give in opposition
against God's people and against the
truth mm-hmm all right well I hope that
helped a little bit Becky you know what
can we send Becky that gives a little
more information on revelation 16 the
beast a dragon false prophet maybe just
the one on the beast power you might
even talk about that good there we'll be
happy to send that to you back you
anybody wanting to learn more about that
just call 883 five six seven four seven
ask for the study guide on the
Antichrist and we'll be happy to send it
to anyone who calls and asks hey
listening friends I knew it would creep
up on us you can tell we're running out
of time if you've been blessed by the
program go to amazing
facts dot o-r-g you can click donate
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the
arch-villain the birth of evil a
rebellion in heaven
a mutiny that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of even discover God's
amazing plan to save his children this
is a story that involves every life on
earth every life the cosmic conflict if
God is good if God is all-powerful if
God is love then what went wrong
[Music]
what if you could know the future
what would you do what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past Alexander the Great becomes
king when he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy a hundred and fifty
years in advance Cyrus had been named
Rahm was violent they were ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
seek his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
[Music]
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
[Music]